now the streets across town looking a
lot like this Rivers last night and now
neighborhoods are left cleaning up the
mess Mary Jane bellies are joining us
live in a neighborhood near East Las
Vegas that was hit pretty hard by the
storm Mary Jane I can see that tree
behind you wow
we saw the mess this storm made last
night it rained hard flooding roads now
it's time to assess the damage many
neighborhoods across the valley are
reporting downed trees and Scattered
debris
this is the Pinecrest neighborhood near
Sandhill and Flamingo east of the Las
Vegas Strip not one but two downed trees
are blocking the streets all due to the
severe winds from Thursday's storm you
can also see scattered debris and trash
too in the southwest part of Las Vegas
near Mountains Edge Parkway and Fort
Apache the extensive runoff from the
rain continues across the flood channels
and washes leaving muddy and Slick
streets traffic is moving smoothly now
after the Nevada Department of
Transportation cleared a flooded Road on
Washington and I-15 First Responders
assisted drivers braving the flooded
streets some drivers even hesitating and
turning around to find a different route
and we're preparing for another round of
showers tonight with the primary
concerns being flooding and heavy rain
reporting near Flamingo and Sandhill
Mary Jane beliesza live local now